hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
congenital cytomegalovirus updates
on the diagnostic algorithm during the
neonatal period
and beyond i am michelle ashton of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you
by dslr molecular to learn more visit
dshorin.com
now let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
on the far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i'd like to now present today's speakers
dr marianne
leroyz will and tiziana lazaroto
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen marianne and
to fiona you may now begin your
presentations
so cnb is the most frequent cause of
congenital infection uh the worldwide
prevalence
is was seventh
one thousand births in two meta-analysis
of the literature and the prevalence in
europe
was four uh per
one thousand births in six screening
purposes
most it's the most common non-genetic
cause of hearing loss
and a major contributor to permanent
neurological visibility
the fetal infection may occur after
three types
of of
a mutant infection either a primary
infection
or a reinfection indeed reinfection
are possible because
the immunity is incomplete and second
there there are high genetic diversity
among cmd strains
and a fairly positive person
can be reinfected with a new strain
genetically distinct
and the present woman can be infected
through
a reactivation of a androgenous
latent strain material
can lead to placental infection and then
to
fetal infection the transmission rate to
the fetus
is 30 to 40 after a primary infection
and is unknown after a reinfection or a
reactivation
but is thought to be much lower around
four to five percent so non-primary
infection
meaning reactivation or reinfection
explains approximately 50 percent
of congenital congenital cmd infection
in european countries
i've reported here in that slide the
result of two screening studies in
europe
the first one was held in france
by our group and we screened nearly 12
000 neonates knowing that the matron of
zero prevalence in our population was
sixty percent
and the rate of seeing the infection at
birth was zero point
three seven percent
fifty two percent of uh the the infected
neonates
were infected following a maternal
primary infection
and 48 percent were infected following a
non-immature
non-primary infection the other study
was held in finland they screened nearly
uh twelve thousand donates the
mathematic events was sixty-two percent
in their population
and the cmb infection at rates at birth
was 0.2 percent 47 percent
of these neonates were infected
following a maternal primary infection
and 53 percent following imagine a
non-primary infection
it is very important to understand that
long-term sequelae are equally frequent
after a month in a primary infection or
a maternal
non-primary infection and you see here
in that slide
a table who came from
a meta-analysis of the literature that
shows that hearing loss
and neurodevelopmental disorder were
equally
frequent in babies infected after
primary infection
or after non-primary infection
another important notion to understand
is
that after a matter of primary infection
almost
all long-term tequili are seen when
marginal primary infection
has occurred in the first trimester of
pregnancy
and you see on that slide a table coming
from a meta analysis of the literature
that shows and you can see that
hearing loss and neural developmental
impairment
in infected fetuses was
came in
at a frequency of 23 percent after
infection
uh when the babies were infected after a
mutant infection in the first trimester
and the long-term sequela were close to
zero
when the babies were infected after a
maternal infection
from in the second or in the first
trimester
this link between gestational age and
the risk of sequila
is unknown after maternal non-primary
infection
that is said to be the same meaning
only after a first trimester maternal
infection
so universal neonatal screening is
not recommended in any country
however neonatal journalism is
recommended
when a matter of primary infection has
been documented
in the presence of compatible neonatal
symptoms
or inherently failing universal hearing
screening
knowing that neo-natal hearing screening
will only detect
20 to 60 percent of congenital
cmd-related hearing loss
indeed it meets the late unsafe cases
so neonatal diagnosis must be done
within three weeks
after birth indeed if you do
if we do a ptr later and the pcr is
positive
it can be congenital infection of course
but it also can be
first early postnatal infection
so the method to use is pcr culture
should not be considered
anymore because it's less sensitive than
pcr
the sample we can use for neonatal
diagnosis
is urine or saliva which are
equally rich in viral dna
usually saliva is preferred because it's
easier to collect
and the sensitivity is similar in both
types of samples
however the specificity is lower in
saliva
with positive predictive value around 50
percent
and this because the presence of low
amount of cmd dna from
breast milk or genital secretion may
contaminate
saliva at sampling so a very important
message here
a positive result in saliva should be
checked
in the second sample of saliva or urine
so this slide resume how to
do a neonatal saliva sampling
first you have to collect saliva in
between fittings
usually before the next feeding you
have to check for the absence of mutton
and milk
in the neonate's mouth if milk residues
are visible
you have to eliminate them with a
sterile compress
and this tape is important to avoid
contamination of the saliva samples with
cmd dna from
maternal milk then you apply the swap
in the internal side of the cheek for 20
to
30 seconds until the swab is soaked
with saliva and finally you place for
the transplant median and send it to the
lab
qualitative pcr can be used
for uh diagnosis the quantification
in copies per ml or semi-quantification
by ct value may bring further
information
for example it can
it can discriminate between contaminated
samples
and true congenital infection
you see on that slide that in
contaminated samples
the median viral load is extremely low
2.2
log copy per ml while in true
continental infection the medium viral
load in saliva sample
is very high 7.6
log copy per ml
here we tried to look
for saliva viral loads above according
to the trimester of maternal infection
and you can see that if the knowledge
has
been infected after a maternal infection
of the first
or the second trimester the viral load
in saliva is
very high seven point five and seven
point six
uh log copy per ml while if
the baby if the mother had been uh had
had her primary infection in the third
trimester
the value load in the saliva
is much lower 5.8516
log per ml and even you can
see uh in in green here
that the um when the methanol might
primary infection happen after 54 weeks
the viral load in the saliva can be very
low
so cmd dna load in saliva at birth
is high over five large usually except
in cases with late third trimester
maternal contamination
or in cases with contamination of saliva
by martinez and the
dna
to do cmd diagnosis no natasha and
diagnosis
we can use uh the sa simplex
congenital cmdsa from json gesturing
this essay may be
run on it run on the diesel mdx
instrument this instrument
can run eight samples per hour it's
quite easy to use very compact as you
can see in the photo there
it's based on real-time pcr sa without
prior extraction
and it's a run for qualitative
detection of cmd dna in cylinder swaps
and urine collected in neonates less
than
21 days old the detection threshold
is 500 copies per ml
in saliva swab you can see there the
result
of a positive and a negative test
the positive test and the positive cases
see two curves
the green one corresponding to the cmv
target and the purple one corresponding
to
the internal control target and in the
negative results
you only have of course one curve
corresponding to the internal
control
in our lab we did a correlation study
between the reference family this time
pcr from our lab
and the simplexer congenital cmd fa
we tested 50 saliva samples connected
from 50
infants below 21 days of age
and stored in utm transport media
there were 30 positive samples from
infected maryland
and 20 negative samples from uninfected
neonate
and you can see that the concordance
between
the reference lab methods and the
simplexa
essay was a perfect 100 percent
we did a correlate we try to correlate
the simplex ct values and the log values
obtained in positive sample and you can
see also that the correlation was quite
good
it is possible to use whole blood poles
for continental cmd neonatal diagnosis
the sensitivity of cmd pcr in neonatal
blood
is around 90 percent for diagnosis of
all cases of congenital cmb
however the sensitivity in the subgroup
of neonates
who will develop equila is close to 100
percent
in this slide have reported uh the
result of cnb dnr detection and
quantification in all blood samples
at birth in the french cohort of
infected neonates and you can see that
91 percent
of all infected marinades had a positive
cmd pcr
in whole blood but all children
100 percent of children read sequelae at
the positive cmd pcr in all blood
and this is uh similar to the results
obtained
in the u.s coarse where they found that
all chickens with sequila
at a blood viral load at birth over 3.3
log
now which test can we use can be used
for retrospective diagnosis
of continental cmd behind the neolithic
period
can we detect can be dna in saliva
so a positive detection after three
weeks of age
may be due to continental cmd but is
mostly is mostly likely due to a
cosmetic infection
however a negative detection in saliva
in babies less than six months
excludes the diagnosis of congenital cmd
and is unlikely in babies aged between 6
and 12 months
and you can see that on this slide
where i reported the kinetics of saliva
viral load
between a birth and one
and two years of age in our french
french court and you can see that cmd
dna in saliva was positive in 100
percent of congenitally infected
children
up to the age of six months and at one
year
four percent of continentally infected
children
did not have detectable cmd dna in the
saliva meaning that
96 percent had
still dna same dna detectable in the
saliva
for retrospective diagnosis we also can
use
tmb ptr and dbs on dry blood plots
from goofy cars
we have to be aware that the analytical
sensitivity
is lower with dcr
in dbs than with pcr
in fresh all blood
because a small amount of blood is
analyzed
one dbs is only 50 microliters
of blood and second the dna is difficult
to extract from the card
so the detection thresholds of cmd
[Music]
in dbs is uh between
1000 and 10 000
lock copies per ml
depending on the technique used and it's
much lower the sense
of that the sensitivity of cmd pcr
in fresh or blood with uh
analytical sensitivity with uh sorry
detection threshold
between 200 and 500 copies per ml
therefore the clinical sensitivity of
cmd pcr
in dry blood spots is around 70 to 80
percent to detect
all cases of congenital cmd and 90 to 95
percent
to detect all cases with sequelae
in on this slide i try to resume the
algorithm for the diagnosis of
congenital cmd
in a infection in the neonatal period
and behind
if the if the baby is less than three
weeks
what is recommended of course is the cmd
pcr in saliva
or urine if the baby is aged between
three weeks and six months
you can test the same dpcr in saliva
or in urine and it is negative this is
clued
congenital cmd if it's positive you
can't know if it's congenital or uh
pulsating so you have to do the cmd ptr
and dbs from the glute-free carbs
if the baby is over six months
you can do ascending psychology a
negative igg of course exclude
controversial cmd
a positive one it can be congenital or
postmetal
and you can again try to do
the cmd pcr on dbf if the graph record
is still available and if the graphical
is not available as being further away
you have to gather indirect evidences
such as
mathematical reconvertion growth
retardation
compatible abnormalities and cerebral
nerves
so to finish are we ready for
controversial cmd
universal neonatal screening
there are some pros like it's a frequent
condition
the neonatal universal neonatal
screening would
be able to pick up all infected
marinades
those infected after martinez primary
infection but also those infected after
martinal non-primary infection while
if you screen methanol severology
you will only pick up neonates uh
infected
after martinal primary infection
if you do the drag doses you can use the
neonatal treatment by consequent for six
months
and this is um for symptomatic learning
and this treatment is significantly
improved hearing and connective
functions
although mildly and of course it's
beneficial to
have an early detection of hearing loss
because it improves
speech development against
the neonatal screening are first the
ongoing debate on the base
method for this universal screening
should it be salier saliva screaming
which would
obviously offer a bet the best
sensitivity
but it's rather difficult to organize
or should it be uh screening on dbs on
dry birth spots
which would be easy to organize since
dbs are routinely collected at birth
but we really need prospective studies
to establish the sensitivity
of pcr on dbs to be sure
that it detects all cases with sequelae
moreover universal neonatal screening
could raise parent and anxiety
and parental psychological discomfort
and this has to be evaluated
and of course good increased
effectiveness study must be done before
uh implementing the universal knowledge
of screaming
so i finished there and i give
and now suzanna with start her talk
perfect um
we know that that the congenital cv
infection is
a very important public health
and in these slides i would like to
show uh because it is
a public health more children may be
affected
by congenital cmv than
any add other better known childhood
disorder
such as fetal alcohol syndrome down
syndrome spina bifida
and hiv and congenital rubella syndrome
so
in 2015 there is a very important
manuscript by gail demler the
pediatrician houston
and she explained
what is the very important public health
for congenital
infection because she identified the
cmv the elephant in our living room
because it is a major public health
problem
that for date dick days
has been under recognized and addressed
so uh for the pathogenesis
it's very important to know uh
why the spread the virus spreads
via the blood and computers made to do
the fetus
because in this case the placenta
represents an efficient barrier in many
cases
that means that for mother
phytotransmission to occur
in addition to spreading via the blood
that virus must be to able to cross
the placenta barrier here
i reported now the natural history
of cmv human sensitive infection
the virus is present in the blood in the
maternal blood
and infects trophoblasts fibroblasts
endothelial cells and
after virulent replication
in the placenta the virus comes
into contact with the
fetal blood and at this point
we have the fetal infection
and in congenital infection
in the newborns from 10 to 15 percent
of newborns are symptomatic at the birth
and when we have symptoms at the birth
we can recognize the lower weight
fetal retardation petika gender is
hepatosplenomegaly popular sensorineural
hearing loss
microcephaly ocular defects dental
defects
pleumonia and cns
it is a very big
very important problem at the birth
because in this group
we have 10 percent of newborns
at the risk to have mortality in fact
the mortality rate is about
10 percent and furthermore
from 50 to 70 percent of
the symptomatic newborn
we have the risk to develop a severe
sequelae
in asymptomatic newborns
and we recognize a percentage
between 85 and 90 percent at birth
however uh forever
[Music]
eight from 50 percent of them
go on to develop a severe sequelae
in particular when we
recognize the severe sequelae every time
we recognize the sensory neural hearing
loss
and the mental retardation
and in general
uh we we have about
2 out of 1000 newborns suffer
from a congenital symb infection
for the birth prevalence in this moment
every time we say in
countries with low density low
population density
we can recognize a very low
risk of congenital infection
the birth prevalence in these countries
is from 0.5
to 0.7 percent
whereas in countries
with a high population density
the birth prevalence is higher between
eight to two percent
and in this moment is very difficult to
to have a very
clear data because if you
if you read the data in this
table i reported the literature data
very recent
literature data as you can see here
we have very um
the percentages of uh
of the congenitals in the infection at
birth
are very very variable we have
we recognize a significantly variable
in both countries with low
population density and in countries with
a high population density this is the
reason
that today it is very difficult to
identify
a real risk however
we can surely say that
the overall birth prevalence
in the world is of congenital
infection is 0.64
despite these uh
the only nine percent of women
know about simvi before and
during their pregnancy
and
we can say that uh cnb congenital symp
infection
in this moment is a very important
public
as a problem
so for the diagnosis
all consensual documents international
european non-european documents
recommend that the diagnosis neonatal
diagnosis
in the case of documented or suspected
maternal
infection during pregnancy and
in the case of suspected neonatal
cmv disease and in the case of newborns
who fail hearing loss
and i would like now to show our data
our data our results from
a long monitoring and
we identified in
1170 premium women
with a primary infection and non-primary
infection
over a span of 14 years
and in the group of non-primary maternal
infection
we identified 205
women and in this group
we identified 7
and 7 transmission equal to 3.4 percent
and in this group we
identified about 40 percent
of newborns or fetuses with symptoms
in whereas in a primary
maternal infection with 965
in primary maternal infection
and the the percentage
of transmission is 23 percent
and in this group we found 18 percent
fetuses and numbers with symptoms
so this this important
collection of results
is a important collection because
it is in agreement with all literature
data
and confirm the very important problem
for the transmission and for the risk to
have the fetuses
or newborns with the symptoms
after primary and non-primary infection
so when we analyze the data
from newborns infected cmv infected
newborns
in particular over a span of
18 years we found
63 infected symbi newborns
as you can see here and
10 newborns from non-primary infection
equal to 15 percent
and whereas 48 infected number
comes from primal maternal infection
equal to 70 percent
and finally we found a very small group
[Music]
in with a congenital symb infection
five new bones that come from undefined
maternal infection
in this group we recognize that the
maternal infection
but we were not able to identify
if a primary or non-primary infection
so as you can see here when we
analyze the the risk to have symptoms
at the birth and we found that very high
percentages newborns with a symptom at
birth
from mother with a non-primary matter
infection during pregnancy
and we found that a group
with symptoms in newborns
from a primate infection but
in this case the percentage is lower
than the first
so what about
now for the screening i confirm
the opinion and mariana explain
which are the reason in this moment
uh universal neonatal screening is not
is not recommended okay
but in united
states there is a very important
experience
in particular the national cmb
foundation
is a non-profit organization as
partly determined the introduction and
passage of our legislation
in order to combat the congenitals in
the infection by simply education
and or infants in the screening
the situation at april
in 2019 in
10 states blue collar dark
screening or education has been law
enacted in five
states blue collar
light proposed
the introduction the screening or
education
for in order to combat congenital
infection and finally in
other 15 states with
gray color in the map is under in
discussion this is a
is an extremely important position
and probably it is uh an important
experience for not
fully the united united states
but for all countries in the world
we know that the gold standard for the
diagnosis
and for the screening is the
urine and saliva real-time pcr
it is very important to have the
examination during the first
three weeks of life this is a very
important point
because after that time it may represent
an infection
acquired at birth or during the
neonatal period for the screening
which is the opinion of the
international comm community i think
this
is we are very agree with the
manuscript manuscript published by
gail damler in 2020
in clinical infectious diseases newborn
screening for
congenital civil infection it is a time
and in the last
the last years probably so many
manuscripts
publish a different experience
and a different approach for
cmv congenital screening and probably
this is the reason that it is the time
to to introduce
this screening in
in any car in each country
and introduce the possibility to test
all new at birth
so uh which is the the
real reason cv is okay
cm is the major cause of childhood
disability
but frequently goes undiagnosed
it is very important to have early
diagnosis because
it is possible to offer antiviral
therapy for selective
infants and is very important to have
early diagnosis early screening
for early intervention for hearing loss
and we are agree that the saliva
is a preferred sample type for cmb
screening
in newborns and
the results that we obtain from
alabama group from surash bopana in
2011 sorry
2011.
the the data the published data
were very important because
the group recognized this very high
sensitivity 100 percent
and very high specificity for
the saliva sample used to screen for
congenital
infection however when we test
the real-time pcr saliva sample obtain a
positive results it is
also mandatory to test urine sample due
to the high level
of possible contamination with the
breast milk
now i would like to show
some data that we obtain some results
that
we obtain with our experience
with these new real-time pcr
the name is simplex it is very similar
to
data just presented by mariana
so i think this is an
important experience because
the this qualitative detection of
cnd cmv dna
is important because we can use
unprocessed
saliva schwab and unit samples
so we are able to
process the the samples without
preliminary extraction
and the system is associated with
eight reusable wealth signals for direct
amplification targets in about one hour
from one to eight sample per time and
then a very important
point is the possibility to have an
internal control to in order to
validate the negative results
our study analyzed 60 set
of samples archived
and a 30 sample saliva
collect in with utm
swaps and 30 urine sample
form nano newborns
before 21 days old
and in the first table
i show you the positive results positive
results
in saliva and urine and
we evaluated the
the results obtained during the routine
with our reference method
positive results in all samples
urine and saliva and we obtain
the same results with the simplex
congenital symbilias on m dx
and the agreement was 100 percent
in both fluid
biological samples said
same results we obtain with negative
results
saliva and urine 15 samples
we also in this case we compare
the reference method with the in the
simplex method and the agreement we
obtained
100 of agreement
and another important point
for is when we analyzed the
average threshold times the city
for positive saliva and urine and
the city for all
for all samples were between
24 and 25
in all positive samples and in
all negative samples uh the
of the the the amplification of the
internal control
were with an average of
a city of 29
so it is an important part because
the the system is
easy and it is
rapid that can aid in the quick
and correct diagnosis of congenital symp
infection
and it is possible to test
in the same run both saliva
and urine samples so
i would conclude my presentation
with the results that
we obtain after
a prospective multi-center clinical
trial
and we presented the schedule
of our prospective multi-center trial
during the last international congenital
cindy conference
was held in the united states in
birmingham
in april 2019
and this is the first time that
i showed the data now because
we concluded that the study just
[Music]
at the end of august and
of this year and the title of
these prospective multicenter clinical
trial
is the identification of a cmv dna
catastrophe in saliva sample
for the diagnosis of congenitals in the
infection
it is a multi-center clinical trial and
there are three centers the first center
here in bologna in my hospital the
second center
is a hospital very close
to milan and the last hospital is
in south italy uh barry and
we have a twins the first is
a viral dna cut off well in saliva can
discriminate
a congenital infected newborn from
a non-congenital infecting one
the second is if a subsequent
saliva sample is indicated a
confirmatory
testing for congenital symb infection
diagnosis or it is mandatory to test
a neonatal urine sample so
this is our our results
and we found 40
sorry 54 saliva sample
and in this group we obtain uh
in the first swap a false positive
results
in particularly the percentage
is higher is 1.7 percent
so as you can see here in the table
in 50 samples
we obtain false positive results only
in the first saliva swap
and we obtain in the second saliva swap
negative results the same in urine
sample
however in four samples
we obtain positive results false
positive results
in the first schwab however
we obtain again positive
false positive results in the second
saliva schwab
and in the urine we obtain
a negative results so in this case
in our experience and
out of 4 54 samples
with fourth positive results in the
first
schwab we obtain four saliva specimens
and four seconds saliva schwab
with false positive results
and for the in this group
we enrolled 3151
newborns and we
recognize the 21
newborns with the congenital symb
infections
and the
birth prevalence was
0.66
and it is in agreement with the
literature data
and in this group we obtain
a positive results in the first
in the second shops
and in all urine samples
and disagree with mariana data because
we found in all cases
a very high low very high
viral load so this is a reported in
these slides
the viral load that we
in saliva schwab and the urinary schwabs
sorry in the urine samples in the 21
samples from newborns with congenital
single infection
finally i would like to show uh
which is the the
results uh in relation
to to have the symptoms at birth
and we have we
recognize 10
newborns renewables
with congenital infection from
primary maternal infections and
two newborns in particular two newborns
have severe symptoms and
both receive therapy by the cyclovir
therapy for six months so
we had
seven new bonds come from
a non-primary maternal infections
and three newborns
from a noun maternal infection
so in this case the mother did not
receive any tests before or during
the pregnancy and finally one newborn
from
undetermined maternal symbi infection
during the the monitoring after the
delivery
we identify a baby
with monolateral deafness and
we identify this symptom at five months
until after the birth so
in conclusion i
would like to report here
and in the next slide the principle
takeaways of the diagnosis
and the screening of congenital symb
infection
i think it is important
to to to follow
the the recommendation
for the diagnosis and for the screening
in particular for the the material that
we analyzed and it is very important
take a caution approach when
interpreting the positives in cindy
screening results
by testing a subsequent saliva sample
in this moment probably is better to use
every time in the urine as a
confirmation material for
congenital screening or diagnosis
for cmb infection and finally
it is very important uh to
to underline that an infant
with congenital single infection must
must undergo clinical laboratory and
instrumental assessments within the
first month
of life this is an important point
because it is very important
to identify newborns very early after
the delivery
thank you and thank you for your
attention
thank you marianne and tuviano for your
informative presentations
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for all right let's go ahead
and get started
okay so our first question is for you to
zionna
while universal screening is not
recommended by any
european union authorities could the
targeted screening approach
be reliable and applicable in terms
of cost effectiveness strategy
yes it is very important but
so hard question because
in this moment
we we we are
we are we agree that is
the time to have the
neonatal screening but in this moment
we don't have a very important
experience
in terms of cost effectiveness strategy
so i remember some
publication from germany from other
european countries but
it is very difficult to
explain with numbers
uh the
the the problem when we don't have the
possibility to identify
very early the infected
sin be infected newborn
so i think
this is important
to to follow the
american experience in this moment
because
they did
only from this important american
experience
we have the possibility to understand
very well
which is the real
the real approach
to in order to identify very early the
infected cmv newborn
thank you so much since
dbs as a matrix for congenital cmv
infection detection
shows low sensitivity do you have
experience
in the use of amniotic fluid if yes
is there a correlation in detection
between amniotic fluid
and saliva samples
yes there is a correlation in detection
between
amnetic fluids and saliva samples
and when cmdpcr
is positive in amniotic fluid
same dpcr is always positive in the
saliva
sample at birth but
when the cmpcr is negative in a mutic
ring during pregnancy
in 95 percent of cases the cmb pcr
is negative in the saliva at birth
and but in five percent
the pcr is positive in saliva
even if the the pcr was negative in
amniotic fluid
these cases are rare and they are
explained by a length passage
of the virus after the time that the
amyocytesis was done to retrieve
the amniotic fluid and they have very
good prognosis
these cases have very good produces
great thank you so much and now your
next question is for tijana
as you mentioned and as reported in the
scientific literature
urine is the matrix of choice to confirm
confirm
a positive saliva sample for congenital
cnb infections
are there differences in cmv detected
between two matrices
for positive samples
yes my my answer is
come from my data my last results
because in our experience
in a few cases only four cases
in a very small group
but we obtain a positive
results uh with a very
very the load the viral load is very low
but we obtain the second
collection of saliva
are positive results this is the reason
that
probably the urine is
the metrics of choice to confirm
the in the infection and
because if you use a
qualitative pcr
and if you don't don't
do not do sorry do not check
the city and uh you don't have the
possibility to recognize the
viral load is possible to have a a
positive
results in the second collection
and you
recognize a false congenital sin the
infection
so in this moment uh probably it is
better to have
cautions to to consider the
the second saliva swap as
as a
as a sample
control sample
thank you so much and i'll take time for
one more question and this one's for you
marion
why is the threshold of three weeks for
the correct sample
collection for congenital cnb detection
importance
yes uh indeed cmp a diagnosis must be
done within the first three weeks of age
and because if the cmv pcr
in saliva is positive after three weeks
of age
you cannot tell if it is a congenital
infection or a postnatal
one so postnatal infection can be very
early because the baby can be
infected through birth
through the passage in the the birth
canal and it can be affected with
mutton and milk as we say so
it's important because we know that only
congenital
infection can lead to long-term sequity
and post-metal infection are mild
and they do not lead to long-term
sequelae so it's important to
have a differential diagnosis between
congenital and postnatal infection
thank you again marianne and tiziano for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor
dsor molecular for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their questions as a reminder
any questions we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time take care goodbye